so at the top you've got the uh the
cladding and then you've got the wooden
balconies for four and a half years mike
gross has been in limbo he can't sell
his flat in this tower block because of
fire safety issues that could cost 14
million pounds to fix
when the government announced a building
safety fund last year to do exactly that
he told me it gave him hope
but 11 months on with a new government
promise he is no further forward i
welcome what michael gover said i think
it's a positive step forward
but for ourselves we're still waiting we
applied for the building safety fund
about a year ago and
we've not
got any money yet we're still waiting we
don't know how long we're gonna be
waiting and you're still having to pay
out yes we're still paying out and i
think we'll be paying out for a long
time
the grenfell tower fire in 2017 killed
72 people and exposed a fire safety
scandal with building blocks wrapped in
combustible cladding or with balconies
that burn and faulty fire doors
after five billion pounds of public
funding there are still thousands of
leaseholders who face crippling bills
now the government says the developers
must pay to those who missed dangerous
products like cladding or insulation to
those who cut corners to save cash as
they developed or refurbished people's
homes and to those who sought to
profiteer from the consequences of the
grenfell tragedy we are coming for you
it's the gray stuff at the top for the
first time leaseholders like liam in a
low-rise block are being acknowledged
but it's not clear if issues other than
cladding will be included i'm cautiously
optimistic but it's a guarded welcome
we've been here before with the
government making a big money
announcement that grabs the headlines
allows them to get legislation through
parliament and then nothing changes so
we need to see
the details of how this plan will be
delivered the government says big
developers must come up with plans to
replace dangerous cladding by march or
face a new tax to pay for it geraldtop
sky news